tous
[Musique]
nous sommes avec guillaume cayol dans
les coulisses du groupe jc decaux
l'atelier de préparation des affiches
bonjour bonjour nicolas
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire combien
de personnes travaillent ici dans cet
atelier cet atelier à 135 personnes qui
travaillent et au global sur l'a330
préparation qui en france 1 2 dans les
yvelines et un en rhône alpes on a au
global de 34 personnes et alors quelles
sont les différentes étapes de
préparation des affiches la première
étape et la réception de dijon reçoit
des affiches imprimées sur du papier fsc
issu de forêts gérées durablement
ensuite on va la première étape sa
lettre est la réception des photos qui
va être ensuite complètement
informatisé rentrée notre système et
ensuite on va préparer l'ensemble des
affiches vous voyez ici comme ça on va
si on va aller colisée sa deuxième étape
on va faire du colisage on va dérouler
pour ensuite comme vous allez le voir
sur les images et derrière faire des
colis pour chaque affiche à chaque
affiche va recevoir ces affiches
identifiés pour lui-même donc là c'est
des affiches de quoi en fait c'est pas
forcément la publicité vous m'avez dire
tiens aujourd'hui on nous prépare un
cent mille affiches par semaine tous ses
locaux on a à la fois des campagnes pour
des annonceurs nationaux des annonceurs
locaux pour l'équipement des commerces
de proximité de la ville de plaisir mais
aussi pour la coller les collectivités
qui nous mine qui pour les gamins ils
peuvent communiquer sur nos dispositifs
sert présent quasiment 20% de
préparation donc finalement fait c'est
rouler les affiches pour qu'elle soit le
plus propre possible à l'affichage on va
dérouler en fonction des formats on va
aller rouler pour le démettre ion le
rôle de 8 mètres carrés que vous allez
on va avoir maintenant on va les
assemblées en assemblée affichons val
d'escaut tiers on allait conditionner on
va déconditionner pour que le travail
sur le terrain soient le plus simple et
plus facile possible pour l'affichage
allons vous justement vous parlez des
affiches de 8 mètres carrés justement
vous avez des nouvelles machines des
systèmes automatiques on va tout de
suite aller découvrir
et nous sommes toujours avec guillaume
ferriol pour parler de ce système
automatique qui assemble des affiches de
8 mètres carrés cette fois-ci cédé à
nicolas dans cette machine est
complètement automatique on a des
machines semi automatique mais cela est
complètement automatique et vient
m nous comme vous pouvez le voir à
l'écran des avis en charge des hâtifs
débat d'afficher des halls affiche
automatiquement la machine grâce à des
caméras qui sont positionnées dans la
machine bien repérer des croix
d'assemblage est bien positionnée
parfaitement la plus pour avoir un
assemblage parfait c'est cette partie là
donc ça c'est un système automatique
mais il ya aussi des collaborateurs qui
font cette activité-là cette activité là
elle est principalement réalisé par nos
collaborateurs puisque plus de la moitié
se fendit concentrent des applis sont
produits par nos collaborateurs et de
machine s'est mise automatique la force
de jc decaux c'est d'avoir à la fois des
machines manuel semi automatique est
automatique pour pouvoir adapter notre
outil de production à l'eau type de
campagne que l'on réalise en ou sur la
dernière étape c'est la partie
préparation rangement et ensuite
livraison on a fait le choix si ici des
taux d'internaliser complètement nos
livraisons on a treize navette qui vont
parcourir qui partent le lundi matin
le livret l'ensemble de nos sites en
france nos 86 et juste avant on a le
rangement de toute la production qui est
systématiquement contre les scanner doit
être sûr d'avoir le jour j à l'heure h
l'ensemble des affiches prête en tout en
france eh bien merci guillaume cayol
merci décollage